yeah
um
let's here let's let's let's uh focus
first on this notion of right of being
aggressive right aggression both sides
of the ball will do it now todd bowles
uh maybe a little too aggressive in
going single coverage on tyree kill when
they played back in week 12 but let's
just look at the mindset of andy reid
and eric b enemy going against todd
bowles and just that mentality of how
they may try to attack each other will
they be careful will they go for it well
i i think andy reid and company will go
for it i don't think they're going to be
careful now they'll be careful in the
sense i think mike of you know being
conscious of protecting mahomes would
like we've talked about the moving in
the pocket i would think you know they
spread the field and get short passes
and get the ball out of his hands that
way right so and then of course we're
going to see all the movements and
motions and things like that i don't
think kansas city
kansas city
their offense is arguably the greatest
unit in the league right they're not
going to bow down to anybody they're
going to make people adjust to them i
mean that's just the simple fact of the
matter and that's where it's awesome
because you know you just said it
aggression todd bowles is famous for
blitzing and having creative blitzes and
i would just say
man
if there's a week to ever have opposites
day for your this is it like he can't
blitz mike that that would be the number
one thing i would say
they blitzed a hand ten times the first
time around we talked about it yesterday
mahomes was six for nine for 114 yards
and two touchdowns and it was almost
worse than that even on the three in
completions it could have been bigger
stats so that's where i think the first
adjustment of the game is is todd bowles
you can't beat todd bowles it's going to
have to be a different sunday this week
because of the chiefs and and patty
mahomes in town
well and
with the offensive line of the kansas
city chiefs right
it potentially allows the buccaneers to
not yeah splits right now jason pierre
paul we got to see what his final
designation is today he's got that knee
problem but
if you can
create pressure on patrick mahomes
without sending extra guys and that was
the dean p's when he was the titans
defensive yeah that was his approach to
patrick mahomes he's still gonna get the
ball off if you blitz him so what's the
point you may as well use those guys in
coverage right so
without eric fisher without mitchell
schwartz who remains on injured reserve
and hasn't been activated and likely
won't be activated you got mike
remembers plus i can't remember who i
don't know who the right tackle is going
to be all i know is shaq barrett and jpp
are going to be trying to get around the
end and get after patrick mahomes and
patrick mahomes foot which he
said will be 100 percent that big toe
that turf toe that he had he's going to
be getting his cardio in because i think
he's going to be moving around a lot on
on sunday kind of like what we saw him
do last year to get away from nick bosa
and company no doubt it's going to be
one of the keys to the game but mike i
think that's like
that's the point as far as what you
started off saying you know it is they
got the flexibility right they got a
front four
that's special they got three first
rounders on the front four and shaq
barrett who's a middle round guy who led
the nfl and sachs last year in 2019.
you know their team and a lot of it is
built around that front four well now
now's took the time to pay the pied
piper i don't know if i said that right
but it sounded good coming out of my
mouth all right but either way now's the
time this is why you're here it's this
game it's this moment yeah you front
four against like you just talked about
that offensive line and guys that we
don't know
right
they they gotta dominate that crew and
and to me that is the key of the game
you i mean mike i don't know i mean
would you blitz patrick mahomes and
company i just ask you no right no i
wouldn't no you can't and i would say
also there's a fine line where
no three-man rushes either you can't do
a three-man rush because he'll just buy
time that means there's gonna be two
double teams and then one guy that's
going to be one-on-one great he's going
to make that guy miss and buy time and
now you can't cover forever so that
front four it is on them i look at it in
a lot of ways mike where i just go
it's that front four it's drop seven i
think you heard me say this but it
almost needs to be like new york giants
playing the play in the buffalo bills in
super bowl 25.
just continue to play front four two
deep back and go run it please run it
we're begging you to run and
off of that i go kansas city you can't
fall in the trap and run it you can't do
that you don't want to do that either at
least in my opinion
same game plan from super bowl 36 bill
belichick same defensive mastermind
dared mike martz the exact coach to run
the ball with marshall faulk and he
refused he kept throwing into now
belichick did a lot of three man not
before man but same idea you got to do
two guys on tyreek hill please
buccaneers don't experiment again with
single coverage on tyree kill right like
you did in week 12. don't do it you got
to double him and you got a double
kelsey you got to put four guys on two
then you got to take your chances with
the other let me do the math here you
got four guys rushing four guys covering
two you got three guys left for the
other three three or four guys that are
going to be in the pad you got to sing
you got to hope that single coverage of
the other guys is going to hold up but
there's you know the only guy you don't
account for then is mahomes and he could
take off running the football and we've
seen that yeah we've seen that and i
look
when a guy
decides to run the football he becomes a
running back and that's all i'm going to
say about it
because i said enough last year yes you
did well listen yeah they got to be
physical if he's going to try to run and
do those things but you know you said it
yeah belichick right and the rams
patriot super bowl you know belichick
versus the bills and jim kelly and
company and all those type of things but
like you said also those are three man
rush approaches you can't do that
mahomes is a lot more athletic than jim
kelly and kurt warner that you need that
extra guy to pursue him or he's just
going to continue to buy time against a
three-man rush and tear it apart so
that's where i look at it and yeah tampa
like you said it's all about coverage i
don't think they can really consistently
match up and play man-to-man against the
kansas city chiefs or do that stuff like
you're talking about it is it's help
those guys you know whether you double
them or at least they're hey we got a
guy here you know we're looking for
tyreek hill to cross the field so that's
really all he's aware of they need those
extra guys to you know clog some holes
carlton davis one of the guys that had a
long long day when the buccaneers and
the chiefs got together in week 12. here
he is talking about his inclination to
be aggressive in sunday's game
gonna bring the same mentality you know
i'm always be myself
uh
and it didn't work out the first game as
far as what we did and our game plan but
we've corrected it
and uh we got a great game plan going in
and i'm but i'm going in with the same
mentality and that's to dominate so
just look out sunday
and look that's what they need to do a
different game plan here is carlton
davis one in coverage in week 12 versus
the rest of the season a week 12 did not
work out well
15 targets
12 receptions for 236 yards he was great
the rest of the year did great they they
do need to figure out
a better game plan than what they used
in week 12. now i want to make sure i
understand what you're saying if the
buccaneers do what we think they should
do
and basically dare the chiefs to run
should the chiefs run or should patron
homes just be patient and wait for
someone to spring open assuming he can
buy time long enough for someone to
spring open i think that's it mike i
think if we're sitting here monday
morning going the chiefs ran the ball
well we're going to go with the
buccaneers are the super bowl champions
i mean that that's to me you know oh
they ran the ball you know well against
the bills in week six there and there
they were 225 yards rushing and the
bills had the ball with a chance to go
down and score and win the game you know
you know mike i mean i think you and i
are in agreement here it's it's
carlton davis is a real good player
but this is that's a different animal
you can't that's tyree kill it's
arguably the fastest guy in the history
of football they're a different animal
and yeah i believe that even if the
bucks are playing too deep four-man rush
don't fall in the trap kansas city
that's that that to me is what i would
tell them you know you know your your
your bread and butter bread and butter
your money maker
is
hill kelsey mahomes watkins nicole
hardman it's the greatest unit in
football so you can't get in the biggest
game and now go well they're playing a
defense that takes that away so we're
gonna go to our b minus run game now to
do that no they got to go down swinging
with their best punches and you know
whether it's deep zones or things like
that that's where they got great mike
right it's like oh it's too deep it's
zones and then he's patient and throws
it short oh it's man-to-man now it's
time to take your shot patty mahomes and
i just think that should kind of be the
formula for them off of what we talked
about from the buccaneers perspective
and their defense i don't know you and
you tell me if you agree with that or
not or do you think they should run the
ball
when you explained it that way it
reminded me of the story of bill
belichick super bowl 25 your dad's new
york giants
him going into the defensive meeting
room and introducing the concept to
lawrence taylor and company that if
thurman thomas has over 100 rushing
yards will win this game right and i
think they wanted to strangle him when
he said that because they took great
pride in stopping the run they took
great pride in not allowing someone to
rush for over 100 yards but he sold them
on the idea that you drop back you cover
yeah you take steam out of the k-gun
offense and you force them to run the
football and they they did they did take
the bait and they did run the ball and
the giants did barely win that game and
i i tend to agree with you that they
have to keep the chiefs have to keep
throwing the ball right even if it is
short passing someone will eventually be
open exactly right if if patrick mahomes
can buy the time someone eventually gets
open even if you drop seven guys into
coverage and double travis kelsey and
double tyree kill all game long there's
going to be someone who gets open if
mahomes can can just move enough to out
maneuver jpp and shaq barrett yeah i
agreed i mean hey listen this is a tough
task there's no doubt the buccaneers
defense is good but we're i mean really
in in reality we're talking about all
all-time offense an all-time offense so
this is not going to be easy i know the
way we're kind of laying it out there
right now people might be like well then
wait do you think the bucks can actually
stop them
no not really no i don't i don't but i
do think that maybe if they play that
way
that maybe it limits for okay now we're
not blitzing tyree kill catches a slant
and at least we got an extra guy there
to tackle him instead of him running for
70 yards um and then of course not
leaving him on an island with you know a
carlton davis and doing those things
that gives you a chance and to me at
least gives
now your front four a chance to maybe
make that strip sack fumble or tyreek
hill catches the ball and gets hit just
as he's catching it and he fumbles it's
going in in my opinion to take that type
of play or thing to kind of swing back
the momentum in tampa's favor here
because i i do think that the chiefs are
a little bit better
and you know
it's one thing to go back and look at
chiefs versus bucks from week 12 there
may be some value in going back and
looking at super bowl 54 because
for most of the game what the 49ers did
yeah worked
and that 10-point lead that felt like it
was gonna be enough evaporated quickly
this buck's offense which we'll talk
about later in the program better
as good if not better yeah than the san
francisco offense last year because of
the difference between brady and
garoppolo right
what uh what what a weird time for a
connection between those two to pop up
because i wasn't thinking of that going
into the comparison my point though is
maybe what the buccaneers need to do
understand that you know the chiefs may
take them a little while to get going
you got to jump on them or you got to
try to build a lead you got to try to
you got to try to get them in a spot
where
maybe that mistake is going to come yeah
maybe patrick mahomes is going to get
rid of the football before he's ready
and maybe devin white is going to be
there to make a play or colton davis or
antoine winfield jr or somebody's going
to make a play and keep the chiefs from
matching whatever the bucks you're able
to do or if the bucks can build a lead
to keep the chiefs from chipping away at
it now that's not going to be easy
because patrick holmes is patrick
mahomes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports